while his body moves up and down so if
he's on a tree branch on a windy day he
can find his
food wow pretty cool and do it
again to the
music yeah now you're making me feel
dirty all right and they'll eat lizards
and snakes so unlike their namesake king
fisher they will eat fish but they'll
also eat a lot of other things
too that's really cool and they'll
vocalize like that as a territorial call
and also to attract a mate this is like
the hardest intro
[Music]
ever it's a cabar it's a cabar you want
to hear him yeah all right if you make
the noise he might sing back what let
him make the noise all right come on
Music Man Mark he'll sing back to you
will he really we'll
try oh my
God
y can you bring
over you want to bring him over yeah
bring him over
record also known as The Laughing
cabur oh my goodness words can't
describe this song about this episode so
far there go ahead sing something
[Music]
sits in the oldum
tree he really responds though it's
pretty cool you know he's saying the
same thing about you
yeah of it's amazing I was here this
this guy comes in and he sings with me I
got a duet nice isn't that a
great he's laughing at
you they said like a
[Laughter]
monkey I love this I don't want to
interrupt this
conversation what are your thoughts
on I know I know really housing market
is not doing so well these
days the bird need isn't that
interesting it's an interesting
perspective so this is Sophie Sophie
does that's Sophie there but she could
do that that's Sophie in the Proto
Sophie yeah contortion contortion and
shooting uh arrows upside down with her
feet into a Target extraordinary see it
wasn't that scary earlier was it yeah it
was it looks scary I saw he and he does
uh house uh tours oh you do House tours
yeah I tour people's homes oh dope yeah
that's cool people think you're in their
home
yeah this not such a bad thing you've
never no one's ever come up to you and
been like hey are you the guy are you
the guy that tours houses uh you know
come to think of it I've gotten shooted
out of a lot of places we don't want you
in here not totally sure why you have a
song for Sophie dosy and him okay
yeah twist and twist and houses and
homes and twist and twist and houses and
homes home and twist and twist and
houses and home and twist and twist and
houses and H and twist and twist and
houses and home and twist and twist
Andes and home and TST and twist Andes
and home and TST and twist and it and
and TST and TST and it and and TST and
TST and it and home and twist and twist
and and home and twist and twist and and
home and twist TST twist
and TST
[Music]
TST
and
it oh my gosh there we
go I just want to thank everyone so much
I want to thank the academy of Motion
Picture Sciences oh and the MPAA for
sponsoring this
segment
he